Uh oh. So are we saying that in our different monadic verticals, Yes. in C++ we are choosing different names for these? Yes. Oh no. Yes. Is that something we should be sad about? Maybe.
噢。所以我们是说在不同的单子垂直领域中，是的，在 C++ 中我们为它们选择了不同的名称？是的。噢，不。是的。这是我们应该感到难过的事情吗？也许吧。
Maybe? Is that- is that pun intended? Oh, I see. It's optional. No, it wasn't. And then they also have and then, so it's not then and and then. No, it's transform and then oh my goodness So you wait wait wait wait wait wait. I
也许吧？这是——这是双关语吗？噢，我明白了。它是可选的。不，不是。然后他们还有，然后，所以不是 then 和 and then。不，是 transform 和 then，噢，天哪，所以你等等等等等等等等。我
Mean I asked if we should be upset the answer is folks we should be very upset now Visibly losing his cool Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 235 recorded on May 13th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben, we continue our conversation from a few episodes ago about senders and receivers. Today we focus on algorithms. ["Senders and Receivers"] Which makes this episode 235. And I think we are going to, unless if while we were having that last conversation, we wanna start a new undiscussed topic,
意思是，我问我们是否应该感到难过，答案是，伙计们，我们现在应该非常难过。明显失去了冷静。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 235 期，录制于 2025 年 5 月 13 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起，我们继续几期前关于发送者和接收者的对话。今天我们专注于算法。["发送者和接收者"] 这使得本期成为第 235 期。我想我们打算，除非在我们进行上次对话时，我们想开启一个新的未讨论的话题，
we're gonna revisit our last conversation about senders and receivers, which, yeah, we had a lot of great feedback on. People seemed to enjoy the topic and Ben's explanation. And we had said at the tail end of that conversation that we were only scratching the surface and that there's a whole world of algorithms that live on top of this model. And so we would revisit it when we chatted sometime in the future. And that time, I I think has come now.
我们将重温上次关于发送者和接收者的对话，是的，我们得到了很多很棒的反馈。人们似乎很喜欢这个话题和 Ben 的解释。我们在那次对话的最后说过，我们只是触及了皮毛，在这个模型之上还有一整个算法世界。所以我们会在未来的某个时候聊天时重温它。我想那个时候现在到了。
So where should we start? Should we just pick off right where we left off or is there anything you want to say before we... Now there's nothing I want to preface with so let's dive back in. I will accept your praise for the explanation before, although I can't really remember what happened and let's talk more. Well, I enjoyed the conversation, but the praise I was referring to, it came from, I believe,
那么我们应该从哪里开始呢？我们应该就在上次中断的地方继续，还是在你……之前有什么想说的吗？现在没有什么我想作为开场白说的，所以让我们深入探讨吧。我会接受你之前对解释的赞美，尽管我不太记得发生了什么，让我们多谈谈。嗯，我很喜欢那次对话，但我提到的赞美，它来自，我相信，
technically, I do feel like we should do this more. Maybe we'll actually look it up right now in real time, folks. I can't go to Twitter because, I mean, I could go to Twitter, but I'm not going to spend time on Twitter. Actually, I was going to say, because it would take time to hop around. But that's not even true necessarily, because you can just go to the episode and people comment.
从技术上讲，我觉得我们应该多做这件事。也许我们现在就实时查一下，伙计们。我不能去 Twitter，因为，我是说，我可以去 Twitter，但我不会在 Twitter 上花时间。其实，我本来想说，因为跳转需要时间。但这甚至不一定是真的，因为你可以直接去那一集，人们会评论。
But if we go to the GitHub discussion, or actually maybe this wasn't praise necessarily. Paul, who is a attendee of the virtual Meetup that I run, says this is his feedback. At CPP online 2024, there was the evolution of functional programming and C++ by Abel Sen hopefully I'm pronouncing that correctly and two talks on coroutines and a talk on flat Map that I first became confused and then disappointed to find that this is only talking about a new dictionary made from two vectors Working out some good way into category theory for programmers that bind equals fmap then join was a great learning moment in my life. So yes, less praise and more of a comment that he was confused on the overloading of
但如果我们去 GitHub 讨论区，或者其实这未必是赞美。Paul，我举办的虚拟聚会的参与者，这是他的反馈。在 CPP online 2024 上，有 Abel Sen 的“函数式编程与 C++ 的演进”（希望我发音正确），还有两个关于协程的演讲，以及一个关于 flat map 的演讲，我起初感到困惑，然后失望地发现这只是在谈论一个由两个向量组成的新字典。为程序员研究出一种进入范畴论的好方法，即 bind 等于 fmap 然后 join，这是我生命中一个伟大的学习时刻。所以是的，与其说是赞美，不如说是一个评论，他对比 flatmap 的重载感到困惑，
flatmap, which we probably should have mentioned because I think we are both aware of the data structure. Well, and this is the perennial problem here is like what to call the monadic characteristic operation. Haskell calls it bind. Some languages call it concat map also, I think, is in Haskell. That's more specialized for the list monad, I think. Yeah, C++ doesn't have a good term and then is used, but to my mind I don't
这我们可能应该提到，因为我想我们都知道这个数据结构。嗯，这里永恒的问题是该如何称呼单子特征操作。Haskell 称之为 bind。有些语言也称之为 concat map，我想，在 Haskell 中也是。我想那对列表单子来说更专业。是的，C++ 没有一个好的术语，and then 被使用了，但在我看来我并不
I don't think and then is not a natural term for me. So I had seen in the proposal pipeline at some point too that I think transform join because that like we use transform for map. Yeah that would make sense I suppose. Yeah flat flat map did that end up actually getting standardized I don't I can't recall it flat the data structure yes yeah is that C++ 23 26 now you are asking I think it's 26 but I I wouldn't bet on it. Yeah. Uh, oh. No, it might be 23.
我不认为 and then 对我来说是一个自然的术语。所以我曾经在提案管道中看到过，我想是 transform join，因为我们用 transform 来表示 map。是的，我想那说得通。是的，flat map，它最终真的被标准化了吗？我记不清了，flat 数据结构，是的，那是 C++ 23 还是 26？现在你在问我，我想是 26，但我不敢肯定。是的。噢，不，可能是 23。
Yeah, now I think it's... Yes, it's 23. Okay, C++23. That got flatmapped. And... I am now buzzing around Twitter. I went to the... ADSP the podcast Twitter.
是的，现在我想是……是的，是 23。好的，C++23。那个有了 flatmap。而且……我现在正在 Twitter 上四处查看。我去了……ADSP 播客的 Twitter。
And that had some reposts but no comments and now I'm trying to find my repost of the ADSP Twitter and we have almost found it and there's also retweets here I can't find the comments folks but I definitely know I feel like Steve Downey just mentioned on the last episode I think he had a comment about it Where these happened? I don't know. Oh, you know, that's the problem is it's bifurcated It was definitely on blue sky or Macedon. Oh
那上面有一些转发，但没有评论，现在我正试图找到我转发的 ADSP Twitter，我们几乎找到了，这里也有转推，我找不到评论，伙计们，但我肯定知道，我觉得 Steve Downey 在上一集提到过，我想他对此有评论。这些发生在哪里？我不知道。噢，你知道，这就是问题所在，它分叉了。它肯定是在 Blue sky 或 Mastodon 上。噢
And I'm just conflating where commentary happened because They're all you know in my head I see a comment and I'm like, oh it just happened on one of the social quote unquote tweeting platforms. Anyways. Well, okay. So, so back to senders and receivers, the interface on the algorithms. So yes, algorithms. We didn't really talk much about the world of algorithms that live on top of senders and receivers.
我只是混淆了评论发生的地方，因为它们都在，你知道，在我的脑海里，我看到一条评论，我就想，噢，它只是发生在某个所谓的推特平台上。总之。好吧，好的。所以，回到发送者和接收者，算法上的接口。所以是的，算法。我们并没有真正谈论生活在发送者和接收者之上的算法世界。
So maybe that's a good point to pick back up from. You know it's interesting, Eric refers to them as algorithms. I don't really, they don't occupy the same space in my head as like the standard iterative algorithms do for me. But true, they're algorithms. What do you refer, and this is actually maybe we can take a step back because I have in a couple of talks described my algorithm mental model where I think of the C++11 iterator algorithms, the C++17 parallel iterator algorithms, the C++20 range overloads of those algorithms, and then also the C++20 and 23
所以也许这是一个重新开始的好切入点。你知道这很有趣，Eric 把它们称为算法。我并不真的，它们在我的脑海里并不占据和标准迭代算法相同的空间。但确实，它们是算法。你指的是什么，这其实也许我们可以退一步，因为我在几次演讲中描述了我的算法心理模型，我想到 C++11 迭代器算法，C++17 并行迭代器算法，C++20 这些算法的范围重载，然后还有 C++20 和 23
and soon 26 views as also algorithms, even though technically in the standard they are not referred to as algorithms, but all of those I think of as, you know, technically there is a transform in four different flavors, the iterator, the parallel, the range overload, and the view. And I kind of think of those as all as the same thing. Do you have the same mental model? I would say yes. I think of those in the same category. For some reason, I don't think of senders and receivers in the same category, but maybe I should. They are, you know, instead of doing synchronous function calls, they're doing asynchronous
以及很快的 26 视图也作为算法，尽管在标准中从技术上讲它们不被称为算法，但我认为所有这些都是，你知道，技术上有一个 transform 有四种风格，迭代器、并行、范围重载和视图。我有点认为它们都是一样的东西。你有同样的心理模型吗？我会说是的。我认为它们属于同一类别。出于某种原因，我不认为发送者和接收者属于同一类别，但也许我应该。它们是，你知道，它们不是进行同步函数调用，而是进行异步
function calls and the algorithms are the same. But I think because I think because I came from already knowing Haskell, already mapping the concepts to monads and functional constructs, I tend to think of them that way. So when you think of the label on the bucket that these sit in, is it constructs? Is it operations? Do you have a word like algorithms that you use for them or not really? Well, you're not probably going to like this one, but I would mostly say combinators. Combinators.
函数调用，算法是一样的。但我认为因为我来自已经了解 Haskell，已经将概念映射到单子和函数式结构，我倾向于那样思考它们。所以当你想到这些所在的桶上的标签时，是结构吗？是操作吗？你有一个像算法这样的词来称呼它们吗，还是没有？嗯，你可能不会喜欢这个，但我大多会说组合子。组合子。
Interesting. Because most of them are working on their higher order functions, right? They're higher order asynchronous functions. They're composing together functions. I use combinator as a generic term for anything that does that. Like a parser combinator would be another example that I would use. But in this case, it's just a sender combinator. However, the function that composes together more than one sender and gives you back a sender, I would call it, in general, I would call that a combinator.
有趣。因为它们大多数都在处理高阶函数，对吧？它们是高阶异步函数。它们在组合函数。我使用组合子作为任何执行此操作的通用术语。比如解析器组合子就是我会使用的另一个例子。但在这种情况下，它只是一个发送者组合子。然而，组合多个发送者并返回一个发送者的函数，我通常会称之为组合子。
Okay, so now I have a couple questions and we will do our best folks to keep this on topic about senders and receivers. Do algorithms qualify, and when I say algorithms I mean the C++ algorithms we just spoke about, qualify as combinators as well? Probably some do. But honestly, if we take any analogy too far, it starts to break down. I'm sure we could, yes, I think the answer is yes, we could construct a valid mental model where yes, we could say they're all combinators under some definition. But ultimately, this is just, I don't know that it matters too much having different
好的，现在我有几个问题，我们会尽力，伙计们，保持这个话题关于发送者和接收者。算法有资格吗，当我提到算法时，我指的是我们刚才谈到的 C++ 算法，它们也算作组合子吗？可能有些算。但老实说，如果我们把任何类比推得太远，它就开始崩溃了。我相信我们可以，是的，我认为答案是肯定的，我们可以构建一个有效的心理模型，是的，我们可以说它们在某种定义下都是组合子。但归根结底，这只是，我不知道拥有不同的
mental models. It's just your mental model. It's your labeling. And for the listeners that have not memorized my composition intuition talks, combinators definitionally are functions that I'm not even sure if you're supposed to use the word functions, but we'll use the word function functions that rely only on their inputs. Meaning that if you've got a function like, my favorite example is a Forex conversion rate that converts Canadian to US dollars, and it hardcodes some kind of currency right in there. If you're hardcoding a constant that isn't taken in
心理模型是否太重要。这只是你的心理模型。这是你的标签。对于那些没有背诵我的组合直觉演讲的听众，组合子在定义上是函数，我甚至不确定你是否应该使用函数这个词，但我们会使用函数这个词，即仅依赖于其输入的函数。意思是如果你有一个函数，我最喜欢的例子是美元兑换率，将加元转换为美元，并且它在里面硬编码了某种货币。如果你硬编码了一个没有作为参数传入的常量，
as an argument, that's not a combinator. And so in Haskell, a lot of times they refer to reduces and scans as combinators because they're just higher order functions, even the ones that take initial values because there's your fold L and fold L1s. Those are still technically all combinators. And it's one of my least, I mean, it's not just combinators.
那不是组合子。所以在 Haskell 中，很多时候他们把 reduces 和 scans 称为组合子，因为它们只是高阶函数，即使是那些带有初始值的函数，因为有 fold L 和 fold L1s。从技术上讲，这些仍然都是组合子。这是我最不，我的意思是，不仅仅是组合子。
We just talked about flat map. Overloading of these terms is pervasive in computer science. science well having said that I think that most of the most of the things in the senders and receivers bucket do fit that category like Okay, you know so so Well, so let's just talk about them. So so in in terms of the monadic operations, you know There's just, just is lifting a value into sender's world. You give it a value and it gives you back a sender
我们刚才谈到了 flat map。这些术语的重载在计算机科学中是普遍存在的。科学，好吧，话虽如此，我认为发送者和接收者桶中的大多数东西确实符合那个类别，比如，好的，你知道，所以，好吧，让我们谈谈它们。所以，在单子操作方面，你知道，just 就是将一个值提升到发送者的世界。你给它一个值，它给你返回一个发送者
which will produce that value. So that's the same as pure or return is what Haskell would call it. Okay, yeah, that makes sense. And I should interrupt to ask here, because in editing the last senders and receivers discussion, I was upset that I didn't ask this question at the time, maybe because I just didn't think to ask it.
它将产生那个值。所以这和 pure 或 return 是一样的，Haskell 会这样称呼它。好的，是的，这说得通。我应该打断一下问问，因为在编辑上次发送者和接收者的讨论时，我很沮丧当时没有问这个问题，也许是因为我根本没想过要问。
But when you were saying monadic bind, and right now you said monadic operations, are you using the word monadic to you to mean single argument or are you using it to mean the second yes I'm using to mean the functional construct I'm not using it in the array language sense of right now they're dyadic functions which is probably only my problem because array languages use it to mean monadic and dyadic one argument to argument But I remember hearing monadic bind and I wasn't thinking Monadic from like you were thinking single argument bind. Okay. I was I was thinking
但当你提到单子 bind，而刚才你提到单子操作时，你使用单子这个词是指单参数，还是指第二个，是的，我指的是函数式结构，我不是在数组语言的意义上使用它，现在它们是二元函数，这可能只是我的问题，因为数组语言用它来表示单子和二元，一个参数，两个参数。但我记得听到单子 bind，我并没有像你那样思考单子，你思考的是单参数 bind。好的，我当时在想
Yeah So to be clear when Ben or I for this episode use the word monad or monadic we're referring to you know monads as Category theory and more than that, you know, again, through for want of terminology, I sometimes, when I say monadic, I'm actually including the functor, I'm including a functor, I'm including applicative functors, I'm including monads all under that same umbrella.
是的，所以要明确一点，当 Ben 或我在这一集中使用 monad 或 monadic 这个词时，我们指的是，你知道，作为范畴论的 monad，不仅如此，你知道，再次，由于缺乏术语，有时当我提到 monadic 时，我实际上包括了函子，我包括了函子，我包括了应用函子，我包括了 monad，所有这些都在同一个伞下。
Right. And in terms of, you know, that, so just is, is, is pure return or lifting a value into the into the senders world, then then is the characteristic function of a functor. So it's F map, right? It's the same as transform on a vector in the that would be in the list monad. It's the same as transform one optional that would be in the maybe monad on senders it's called then so you want to apply a function to something in the sender change it in some way you know you use just to lift the value and then you use then to change that value right I think and I think that is one of the easier
对。而在……方面，所以 just 就是 pure return 或将一个值提升到发送者的世界，then 就是函子的特征函数。所以它是 F map，对吧？它和向量上的 transform 在列表单子中是一样的。它和可选类型上的 transform 在 maybe 单子中是一样的，在发送者上它被称为 then，所以你想对发送者中的某物应用一个函数，以某种方式改变它，你知道，你使用 just 来提升值，然后你使用 then 来改变那个值，对吧？我想，我认为这是更容易的
it might even be easier than just for some folks, because transform is something you use on a everyday basis. Even if you don't get the idea of kind of putting the parentheses, or I shouldn't say parentheses, the brackets for the list monad, or however you represent an option for a maybe monad, you're used to applying some kind of operation on a sequencer, an optional or something like that. It makes intuitive sense, I think. The listener can send us feedback if it's not the case. And then the next, so then if then is fmap, which is the characteristic function on a functor. Then let value is bind, which is the characteristic function on the monad. Right. And senders calls that let value. So
对于某些人来说，它甚至可能比 just 更容易，因为 transform 是你每天都在使用的东西。即使你不理解那种放入括号的想法，或者我不应该说括号，列表单子的方括号，或者无论你如何表示 maybe 单子的选项，你都习惯于对序列、可选类型或类似的东西应用某种操作。我认为这在直觉上是有意义的。如果不是这样，听众可以给我们反馈。然后下一个，所以如果 then 是 fmap，它是函子上的特征函数。那么 let value 就是 bind，它是 monad 上的特征函数。对吧。发送者称之为 let value。对吧。所以你传递，再次，你传递的不是一个返回常规值的函数，而是一个返回发送者的函数。对吧。而且，then 对应于 flat map，所以 flat map 是 bind，有时在
so in, if we think about stood optional, stood optional has transform, and it has and then, right. And the difference between them really the only difference between them from the outside is that you pass you pass transform a sort of regular function so a function that return a value you pass and then the function that return an optional right so a monadic value because we're in the in the maybe monad in the optional monad. Right. And so, and then on optional is monadic bind. When in senders let value is monadic bind. Right. So you pass again, you pass it not a function that returns a regular value, but a function that returns a sender. Right. And, and then corresponds to flat map so flat map is is is buying is what bind is sometimes called in the
列表单子中被称为 bind，是的，几乎只在列表单子中，是的，我明白了，我明白了，所以 then 等于 bind 等于 flat map 在特定上下文中，也就是列表单子。对吧。等于发送者中的 let value，也就是延续 monad。所以我想，有一个具体的例子吗，比如如果你有一个可选的 int，如果你想做一个加法操作，你不需要为此使用 bind 或 and then。你只需要使用 then。
list monad yes only in the list monad pretty much yeah I see I see so and then equals bind equals flat map in specific contexts aka the list monad. Right. Equals let value in senders, which is the continuation monad. And so I guess, is there a concrete example, like if you've got an optional int, if you're trying to do a plus operation, you don't need to use bind or and then for this. You just use then.
你只需要使用 transform，你只需要使用 buddy transform。是的，这被称为 transform 一个可选类型。是的，抱歉，我们必须导航，是的，我的意思是，这就是问题所在，你知道，它是每一个，它不仅仅局限于单子接口世界，你知道，在数组语言中，他们重命名了一切，每样东西都有六个不同的名字，对吧。这只是旅程的一部分。但如果你想做某事，我想你上次用了这个例子，比如平方根。那不是忽略溢出问题的某种东西，我相信某些听众正在，嗯，如果你在最大 int 处，你做
You just use transform you just use buddy transform Yeah, this is called transform an optional. Yeah, sorry we have to navigate the Yeah, I mean, that's the problem right you know it's every It's not it's not constrained just to the nomadic monadic interface world you know across array languages They rename everything everything's got six different names, and right. It's just part part of the journey But if you're trying to do something, and I think you used this example last time, was like square root. That's not something that is ignoring kind of overflowing issues that I'm sure a certain couple of listeners are being, well, if you're at the max int and you do
加一，它不会……忽略那种东西，当你有一个负数时进行平方根运算，可能是不想定义的。它是一个部分函数。完全正确。所以在那种情况下，加 1 只是 int 到 int，而平方根将是 int 到可选 int。如果你从一个可选 int 开始，
a plus one, it's not going to... Ignoring that kind of stuff, square rooting when you have a negative is going to potentially be something that you don't want to define. It's a partial function. Exactly. And so in that case, plus 1 is just int to int, whereas square root is going to be int to optional int. And if you start with an optional int,
当你使用 bind 时，你最终会得到一个可选 int。所以我想你不能使用，是的，在强类型语言中，你的函数签名必须匹配，你不能用 then 使用一个进入可选 int 的平方根函数。你必须使用 and then。是的，是的。
you will end up with an optional int when you use bind. And so I guess you can't use, yeah, in a strongly typed language where your function signatures have to match, you can't use a square root function that goes into optional int with then. You'd have to use and then. Yeah, yeah.
嗯，就像我们说的，所以 bind 防止你得到双重包装的东西，对吧？因为它先是 FMAP 然后是 JOIN。对吧。所以，让我们做垂直领域。我们有 pure/return，FMAP 和 bind，然后我们有 C++ 发送者领域中的 just then 和 and then，以及 let value 和 let value，是的，and then 在发送者领域中不存在，and then 在可选类型领域中。噢，所以我们是说在不同的单子垂直领域中？是的，在 C++ 中
Well, like we said, and so bind prevents you from getting the doubly wrapped thing, right? Because it's FMAP followed by JOIN. Right. So, let's do the verticals. We've got pure slash return, FMAP and bind and then we've got in C++ sender land just then and and then and and let value and Let value yeah, and then doesn't exist in senders land and then is in optional land Oh, so are we saying that in our different monadic verticals? Yes in C++
我们为这些选择了不同的名称？是的。噢，不。是的。这是我们应该感到难过的事情吗？也许吧。也许吧？
We are choosing different names for these? Yes. Oh no. Yes. Is that something we should be sad about? Maybe. Maybe?
这是双关语吗？噢，我明白了。那是可选类型。不，不是。其实这是 C++ now 的一个讨论话题，有些人正在做一些事情，包括 Steve Downey，他们正在做一些工作试图映射，试图产生表格，对于每一个，我们沿着表格的侧面。你有不同的 monad
Is that pun intended? Oh, I see. That stood optionally. No, it wasn't. Actually, this was a topic of conversation at C++ now and some folks were doing something, Steve Downey included with it They were doing some work to try and map to try and produce The table for each where we're down down down the sides of the table. You have the different monads
你知道，所以可选类型是一个，expected 是另一个，向量是另一个，发送者是另一个。在表格的顶部，你有操作，just F map bind 等等。一个单子组合子的 hoogl 翻译，所以无论如何，我们可以为此感到一点难过，但是的，在发送者中我们有 just，我们有 then，我们有 let value，现在 bind 做的另一件事，let value，它真正是为了运行时选择，对吧？因为你可以根据传递给函数的参数进行选择，你可以选择接下来运行哪种发送者。这体现了
You know, so optional is one expected is another Vector is another senders is another And across the top of the table you have the operations so just F map bind etc. a hoogl translate for monadic combinators so anyway we can be a little bit sad about that but yes in senders we have just we have then we have let value now the other thing that bind does let value, what it's really for is a runtime choice, right? Because you can choose based on the arguments that get passed to your function, you can choose what kind of sender to run next. And that's embodying this
运行时有选择的想法。如果我得到一个特定的值，我可能想做一件事。如果我得到另一个值，我可能想做另一件事。这就是 monad 带来的基本力量，对吧？那种选择。如果你愿意，这就是 monad 在函子之外带给桌面的东西。是 let value，有，我不知道，我想我对这个的反应是，我的意思是，并不是说 bind 一定是一个更好的名字，
idea of there's a choice at runtime. If I get a certain value, I might want to do one thing. If I get another value, I might want to do something else. And that is, that's a fundamental power of monads, right? That choice. That's, if you like, that's what monads bring to the table above and beyond functors. Is let value, is there, I don't know, I guess my reaction to this is that it's, I mean, not that bind is necessarily a better name,
但 let value，我不知道，它没有引出任何关于它做什么的直觉，正如你刚才描述的那样。它来自某个地方吗？就像我不知道它是否来自某个地方，我不知道起源，据我所知，它是为发送者编造的。有 let value，let error 和 let stopped 来处理三个不同的通道。我应该说我刚才只提到了 let value，因为那是快乐路径。
but let value, I don't know, it does not elicit any kind of intuitive for like what it does, as you just described. Does it come from somewhere? Like I don't know it come from somewhere like I don't know if it does I don't know the origin as far as I know it's made up for senders There's this let value let error and let stopped to deal with the three different channels I should say I've just mentioned let value up till now because that's the happy path right
但因为接收者有这三个不同的通道，因为发送者有这三个不同的通道，所以你在它们每一个上面都有一个 let。而 let value 当然是最有趣的，因为在某种意义上，这就是……那体现了你真正想做的事情，那是你想要选择的地方。其他的显然是为了处理错误和取消，先生，对吧？好的，我的意思是，我跟上了。希望听众也是。你对这些名字有什么感觉或想法吗，还是在文档中它就是这样？
But because receivers have these three different channels, because senders have these three different channels, then you have a let over each one of them. And let value is of course the most interesting because in some sense that's what's... that's embodying the thing you actually wanted to do, that's where you wanted the choice. The others exist to handle errors and cancellation obviously, sir, right? Okay, I mean while I'm keeping up. Hopefully the listener is as well Do you have feelings or thoughts about the names of these or it's just it is what it is in the documentation
我，我，我为我的实现写了一些文档，我写了一些类似“如果你认为这些名字不好，别找我”。你知道，去找标准委员会。我只是不想通过更改名称来引入另一个混乱来源。所以。啊，另一个混乱来源。那是什么？
I I I wrote some for my in a documentation for my implementation I wrote something like if you think these aren't good names, don't at me. You know, take it up with the standards committee. I'm just interested in not introducing yet another source of confusion by changing names. So. Ah, yet another source of confusion. What is that?
Yasok 作为缩写？对。你应该放那个。是的，避免 Yasok。是的，所以有趣的是发送者添加了，在 C++ 的结构函数层次结构中还有一件事，在其他 monad 中还不存在，但我们发送者添加了，那就是特征函数在
Yasok as an acronym? Right. You should put that. Yeah, avoiding Yasok. Yeah, so interestingly senders adds, there is one more thing in the sort of functional hierarchy of constructs that doesn't really exist yet in other monads in C++, but we senders adds and that is the characteristic function on
应用函子上。所以 Haskell 中的层次结构有点像函子、应用函子、monad。每个 monad 都是一个应用函子。每个应用函子都是一个函子。但在 C++ 中，我们倾向于不……我们有函子，我们很高兴思考那些。我们有函子，我们很高兴思考那些。我们有 monad，我们很高兴思考那些。我们没有一个具体的化身，一个在 C++ 中形成良好的概念，什么是应用函子的例子。
applicative functors. So the hierarchy in Haskell sort of goes functor, applicative functor, monad. Every monad is an applicative functor. Every applicative functor is a functor. But in C++ we tend not to... We've got functors, we're happy thinking about those. We've got functors, we're happy thinking about those. We've got monads, we're happy thinking about those. We don't have a reification, an idea that's well formed in C++ of what's an example of an applicative functor.
所以我们也不倾向于使用 apply。再次，另一个术语冲突，但 apply 是给应用函子上的特征函数的名字。但在发送者中，我们有 whenall。而 whenall 实际上就是那个特征函数。它是 apply 函数。并且有一个具体的扩展吗？有一个对我们可选 int 的具体例子的扩展吗
And so we also don't tend to use apply. Again, another terminology clash, but apply is the name given to the characteristic function on applicative. But in senders, we have whenall. And whenall is actually that characteristic function. It's the apply function. And is there a concrete extension? is there an extension to our concrete example of optional ints
对于我们的 map 有一个加一，对于我们的 let value 有一个平方根？apply 会是什么？嗯，apply 会像 transform，除了一个作用于多个可选值的变参 transform。我们面临的问题之一是，我们不断定义成员函数，而成员函数本质上是单元的，因为它们处理一个对象。但应用函子，如果我们想要它，如果我们想在可选类型上应用，我们必须制作一个跨越变参可选包的 transform 版本。我在去年的演讲中展示了这一点，是吗？
with a plus one for our map and a square root for our let value? What would apply be? Well, apply would be like transform except a variadic transform that worked over multiple optional values. One of the problems we have is that we keep on defining member functions and member functions are by their nature sort of unary because they have one object that they work on. But applicative, if we wanted it, if we wanted to apply on optionals, we'd have to make a version of transform that worked across a variadic pack of optionals. And I showed that in my talk last year, was it?
是的。我谈到了被遗忘的函数式模式，应用函子。是的。我的脑海里有两个想法。一个是，我看了那个演讲，我觉得我在这里第一次学到东西，所以我显然没有理解你演讲中的内容。尽管我确实记得那是识别 monoid，尽管我肯定会说识别 monoid 对我来说比应用函子演讲更容易掌握。所以我的第一个想法是，好的，显然我没有理解，我需要回去重看那个演讲，因为我没听懂。尽管我现在正在和你说话，所以也许我不需要通过这次对话重看它。我的第二个想法是，你说所有的 monad
Yeah. Where I talked about the forgotten functional pattern, the applicative. Yeah. I have two thoughts in my head. One is that I watched that talk and I feel like I'm just learning something for the first time here So I clearly didn't grok what was in your talk. Although I do recall it was that in identifying monoids Although I definitely will say the identifying monoids one was easier to grasp for me Than the applicative talk. So that my first thought is that okay clearly I didn't understand I need to go rewatch that talk because I didn't understand it. Although I'm talking to you now, so maybe I won't have to rewatch it just via this conversation. My second thought is you said that all monads
都是应用函子，所有的应用函子都是函子。所以我的意思是，所有的应用函子都是函子是有意义的。这是否意味着所有的 monad 在定义上都是变参的？因为以什么方式？如果函子和应用函子之间的区别特征是应用函子是变参的，而所有的 monad 都是应用函子，如果我的理解在我的脑海中是正确的。逻辑结论似乎是所有的 monad 都必须是。变参的。是的，我会这么说。一种，在 C++ 中拼写函数或构建函数结构的自然方式是使它变参，但如果你看 Haskell，
are applicative functors and all applicative functors are functors. So I mean the applicative all applicative functors or functors make sense. Does that mean that all monads are variadic by definition? Because in what way? If the differentiating feature between a functor and an applicative functor is that applicative functors are variadic and all monads are applicative functors, if my understanding is correct in my head. It seems that the logical conclusion is that all monads have to be. Very adding. Yeah, I would say so. One, what the natural way to sort of spell the function or structure the function in C plus plus is to make it very attic, but if you look at Haskell,
Haskell 不那样做，因为 Haskell 没有变参函数。Haskell 有的是部分应用。所以在 Haskell 中，一个 n 元函数实际上是 n 个嵌套的一元函数，对吧？所以 Haskell 能够以某种方式逐个参数剥离，剥离它们或绑定它们，并最终缩小函数的元数。对吧。我们可能不会在 C++ 中那样做。我们只会制作一个变参函数。但它们是等价的。在我的演讲中，我被问到这个问题，这些东西真的等价吗？我在演讲中没能给出一个好的答案，但从那以后，事实上在演讲后不久，我想 David Sankal 问了我那个问题
Haskell doesn't do that because Haskell doesn't have variadic functions. What Haskell has is partial application. So in Haskell, an n-ary function is really n nested unary functions, right? So Haskell is able to sort of strip argument by argument, strip them off or bind them and end up and shrink down the the arity of the function that way. Right. We probably wouldn't do that in C++. We would just make a variadic function. But they are equivalent. In my talk, I got asked the question, are these things actually equivalent? And I wasn't able to give a good answer in the talk but since then in fact very soon after the talk I think David Sankal asked me that question
我们确信是的，它们是，你这样做的方法是，你以两种方式用另一种实现一种，这是完全可能的。我明白了，好的，我想这说得通，这意味着现在我们处于两个垂直领域，或者我想有三个，尽管你说这个 when all/apply 不存在于可选类型和其他单子垂直领域中。据我所知，它不存在于我们可能指出的 C++ 中的任何其他 monad 中。所以它在 Haskell 领域，pure/return，fmap，bind，apply。在发送者中，它是 just，then，let value，和 when all，
we satisfied ourselves that yes they were and the way you do that is you implement one in terms of the other both ways around and it's perfectly possible. I see okay I think this makes sense and so that means now we are at we're at in the two verticals, or I guess there's three, although you're saying that this when all slash apply does not exist in the optional and other monadic verticals. As far as I know, it doesn't exist in any other of the monads we might point to in C++. So it's in Haskell land, pure slash return, fmap, bind, apply. In senders, it's just, then, let value, and when all,
然后在可选类型中，我们会忘记其余的，尽管听起来 Steve Downey 和朋友们构建了一个表格，它是，嗯，其实，我想我们没有涵盖 pure return。它是可选类型只是一个构造函数。是的，然后 Then try 和 try 或 transform。它被称为 transform 一个可选类型。是的，然后他们还有 and then，所以不是 then 和 and then。不，是 transform 和 and then。噢，天哪。所以你等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。我
and then in optional, and we'll forget the rest, even though it sounds like there's a table out there that Steve Downey and friends constructed it is Well, actually, I guess we didn't cover the the pure return. It's the optional just a constructor. Yeah, and then Then try and try and or transform. It's called transform one optional Yeah, and then they also have and then so it's not then and and then. No, it's transform and and then. Oh my goodness. So you wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I mean I asked if we should be upset. The answer is folks we should be very upset. So now if we're visibly losing his cool.
意思是，我问我们是否应该感到难过。答案是，伙计们，我们应该非常难过。所以现在如果他明显失去了冷静。
If we if we ignore Haskell land for a second just stick with C++ folks. If you can visualize this table, we're gonna go left to right through each row so it goes it goes just optional constructor that's fine then we have then transform mm-hmm and then on the next line we have let value and then yeah oh my goodness. What are we? Yeah, we've put then into both columns now in some form. And it seems like it would have made a lot of sense if there was a then that could have been called then and the next one was and then.
如果我们，如果我们暂时忽略 Haskell 领域，只坚持 C++，伙计们。如果你能想象这个表格，我们将从左到右遍历每一行，所以它就是 just 可选类型构造函数，那很好，然后我们有 then transform，嗯，然后下一行我们有 let value 和 then，是的，噢，天哪。我们是什么？是的，我们现在以某种形式把 then 放进了两列。而且看起来如果有一个可以被称为 then 的 then，而下一个是 and then，那会很有意义。
I don't, maybe they were trying to disambiguate so that you don't reach for and then when you want then, but oh boy, oh boy, oh boy. Yeah. Anyway. That's anyway it is what it is all right we won't get upset about the naming so let's draw a line under the functional stuff and and and and talk get back to talking i think more about like let's think of senders as just asynchronous operations again because that might be a bit easier okay yeah i mean that's the problem is you're you're a big fan of Haskell.
我不知道，也许他们试图消除歧义，这样你就不会在想要 then 时去拿 and then，但噢，男孩，噢，男孩，噢，男孩。是的。总之。那是总之，它就是这样，好吧，我们不会为命名感到难过，所以让我们在函数式的东西下面画一条线，然后谈谈，我想更多地谈谈，比如让我们把发送者再次视为异步操作，因为那可能更容易。好的，是的，我的意思是，这就是问题所在，你是 Haskell 的大粉丝。
I'm a big fan of Haskell, so, yeah. As soon as we start talking about this stuff, we're happy to stay in that land. But yes, ignore Haskell from now on and we're back to C++. For folks who are not okay with all of that, or... It might, and indeed for us sometimes, it's easier to think about these things as working on just just the the asynchronous functions. So when all when all is a good example that you can think like for all for all that you can put when all in that box of applicative if that's not intuitive to you, you can equally
我是 Haskell 的大粉丝，所以，是的。一旦我们开始谈论这些东西，我们很高兴留在那个领域。但是的，从现在开始忽略 Haskell，我们回到 C++。对于那些不能接受所有这些的人，或者……它可能，事实上对我们有时来说，把这些东西视为仅处理异步函数更容易。所以 when all，when all 是一个很好的例子，你可以认为，对于所有，你可以把 when all 放在那个应用函子的盒子里，如果这对你来说不直观，你可以同样
think about it like when all it is where it sounds like it you give it a bunch of senders. It gives you back a sender that completes when all of those senders have completed. It's waiting for all of them and then moving on. In that sense, its name is perfect. I mean, that description totally makes sense, and that's good. But when I try to map that back to the fact that if we stay in senders land with then and let value, each of those take a lambda, we'll say. They can take other things, but they take lambdas. Whenall doesn't take a lambda, it just takes senders.
像 when all 那样思考它，它听起来像什么，你给它一堆发送者。它给你返回一个发送者，当所有那些发送者完成时完成。它在等待它们所有人，然后继续。从这个意义上说，它的名字是完美的。我的意思是，那个描述完全说得通，那很好。但当我试图把它映射回如果我们留在发送者领域，用 then 和 let value，它们每一个都接受一个 lambda，我们说。它们可以接受其他东西，但它们接受 lambda。Whenall 不接受 lambda，它只接受发送者。
It takes senders, yeah. So imagine you have two separate computations going on and you want to say I'm done when they're both finished. That's when-all. Okay, I mean, it's like I said, it make when-all makes sense as its behavior, but I guess yeah, we're trying to avoid the functional talk, but my brain is trying to map the, you know, technically the hierarchy of, you know. Sure, sure. You know what I'm trying to say. We'll move on. The point being is that we're exploring an alternative explanation, staying just in C++ land.
它接受发送者，是的。所以想象你有两个独立的计算正在进行，你想说当它们都完成时我完成了。那就是 when-all。好的，我的意思是，就像我说的，when-all 作为它的行为说得通，但我猜是的，我们试图避免函数式谈话，但我的大脑试图映射，你知道，技术上层次结构，你知道。当然，当然。你知道我想说什么。我们会继续。重点是我们正在探索一种替代解释，只留在 C++ 领域。
But yeah, that makes it makes a lot of sense if we just think about it from that. When all take senders as arguments, waits for completion, and then, and let value take operations that have slightly different signatures, but do the same sort of thing. So those four operations, just, then, let value and when all, they give you a really nice set of basis functions that you can use to do a ton of things, right? A ton of things. Most computations are expressible with just those things, in
但是的，如果我们只从那个角度思考，这很有意义。When all 将发送者作为参数，等待完成，然后，then 和 let value 接受签名略有不同的操作，但做同样的事情。所以那四个操作，just，then，let value 和 when all，它们给你一套非常好的基础函数，你可以用它们做很多事情，对吧？很多事情。大多数计算都可以用那些东西表达，事实上
fact I would say. But, you know, and in some sense at this point we move off script as far as standardization towards what the future holds. So more algorithms that aren't necessarily proposed for standardization yet. The existence of when all implies the existence of when any, for example. Right. Right, which you can think of instead of being the and operation, it's the or operation. Right.
我会说。但是，你知道，在某种意义上，此时我们偏离了标准化的脚本，走向了未来。所以更多不一定已经提议标准化的算法。When all 的存在暗示了 when any 的存在，例如。对吧。对吧，你可以认为它不是 and 操作，它是 or 操作。对吧。
Similar to any of and all of. Yeah. And C++. And to bring it back, to just touch back to functional, when any and when all, they're like or and and. When any forms a monoid over senders, right? With the unit of the monoid would be the sender that never completes. When any, if when all is waiting for all senders to complete, that you give it, when any is
类似于 any of 和 all of。是的。在 C++ 中。为了带回来，只是触及函数式，when any 和 when all，它们就像 or 和 and。When any 在发送者上形成一个 monoid，对吧？monoid 的单位将是永远不会完成的发送者。When any，如果 when all 正在等待所有发送者完成，你给它，when any 是
racing senders against each other. Right. Yes. And as soon as any one of them completes, you're done and the others get cancelled. Yeah. You can think of this as the same way as when you implement any of or all of with a std accumulate, although short circuiting aside, which is important, you pass it the std logical and std logical or, but then the identity operations
让发送者相互竞争。对吧。是的。一旦其中任何一个完成，你就完成了，其他的被取消。是的。你可以认为这和你用 std accumulate 实现 any of 或 all of 的方式一样，尽管短路除外，这很重要，你传递给它 std logical and std logical or，但然后恒等操作
are true and false for their corresponding partners. Yeah. So in terms of practical application, when any is pretty important because you can model races, right? I mean, safe races, obviously, but you can race one computation against another. You can cancel something when it's been overcome by events. One simple idea here is imagine you've got a UI and the user sets off some some long-running operation with a progress bar and there's a cancel button right effectively what how you can model that is you're racing the completion of the operation with the completion of the user hitting cancel right that the user pressing cancel is one sender,
是 true 和 false，对应它们的伙伴。是的。所以就实际应用而言，when any 非常重要，因为你可以模拟竞争，对吧？我的意思是，安全的竞争，显然，但你可以让一个计算与另一个竞争。当某事被事件克服时，你可以取消它。这里的一个简单想法是想象你有一个 UI，用户启动了一些长时间运行的操作，带有一个进度条，并且有一个取消按钮，实际上你可以如何模拟它，是你正在让操作的完成与用户点击取消的完成竞争，对吧？用户按下取消是一个发送者，
and the other sender is the operation that's completing asynchronously, and you're racing those against each other. Right, right. That's one example of many. Yeah, yeah, that's one example of many. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com
另一个发送者是正在异步完成的操作，你正在让它们相互竞争。对吧，对吧。这是许多例子中的一个。是的，是的，这是许多例子中的一个。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 adspthepodcast.com
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反括号。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。